February 3rd 2019 so time for another
monthly update video I'm going to talk
about what went on in January what we've
got coming up in February I always like
to begin by highlighting three big
things so big thing number one we've got
a talk here locally in the Milwaukee
area on epictetus slavery and freedom
and the Roman Empire it's kicking off
year four of our philosophers in the
midst of history quarterly series so
that's a big thing coming up big thing
number two last night at some time we
passed the 60,000 subscribers mark on
this YouTube channel which for a
philosophy focused sort of you know low
production high content channel that's
actually quite a big thing and big thing
number three I have taken my oldest blog
or exes D and Ont k and I'm reworking
the format of it so you can expect to
see daily or perhaps every other day
posts shorter as the format coming up so
you know give that a shot I'll take a
look if you're not already a subscriber
to that there's gonna be a lot of
interesting content there January was a
long month but they can never be long
enough for getting done all the things
that I would like to get done of course
but I did get quite a bit in not quite
so many events we had one local talk on
Edgar Allen Poe in the worlds of
speculative fiction series that was
quite good we had some great discussion
actually went on pretty long in that one
I did my online events the AMA which you
can see the video for link to below the
philosophy pop up as well and as usual
you know the half hour Hagel hangouts
and philosophy chat and all those other
things that I offer patreon supporters
but also to the general public I was on
three different podcasts one the
intellectual Explorers Club the other
Tom Ritchie's podcast
and then finally the new faith
colloquium podcast talking about things
from stoicism to anger to alexis de
tocqueville to all sorts of other issues
links to those are also below the
biggest thing I suppose was that my five
classes five college classes that I'm
teaching this semester more than full
time at 4-4 a lot of that my colleagues
out there they all kicked off this month
and then promptly got interrupted by our
snowpocalypse you know the polar vortex
that all of you have heard so much about
and probably seen some some video of you
know we had a name for polar vortices
like that back when I grew up here in
Wisconsin in the 70s and 80s
winter it was like that all the time
cold
you know below zero lots of snow I'm not
quite sure why people get so worked up
about it these days so yeah that that
interrupted classes and you know we're
back to business
we're meeting tomorrow the classes are
more or less going okay I have to do a
lot of work developing content for them
and you know I like to have a lot of
activities and assignments for my
students but that place is a heavy
burden on my on me as well
continued with tutorial work I actually
picked up a few new clients continuing
on at philosophical counseling and
coaching and consulting doing my editing
work for stoicism today you know keeping
that on track and I even got a little
bit of writing in on my own account and
video work I once again did not get my
full quota of Haegele videos done which
was a bit disappointing but I did get
three of them shot so we are making some
progress through this new last section
of the work I shot a lot of class videos
that was part of what was was taking up
my time
some of them I've released the ones on
Aristotle's metaphysics for example I
released the Cicero on fate videos to my
patreon supporters everyone else will
get to see them this coming month
shot some videos and Anselm's Pro slow
Jeon which I've been releasing I also
shot some videos on James Rachel's short
piece the challenge of cultural
relativism which we're using in my
ethics class this semester ethics were
artists and designers and I did a
personal video about our dog Magnus who
we had to put down unfortunately you
know but it is the order of things right
it's fourteen-year-old dog so if you
haven't seen that you can see the link
to that one as well below what do we
have coming up in February well in two
days from the release time of this video
on Tuesday the fifth six o'clock at the
Frank Weinberg library I will be kicking
off year four of our quarterly talk
series in conjunction with with the
Frank Weinberg philosophers in the midst
of history we were already done twelve
sessions over the last three years we do
one ancient one medieval one early
modern one late modern and this time I
picked Epictetus and so we're gonna talk
about you know Roman history and all
these different Emperor's and and how
philosophers got kicked out of Rome and
and brought back and things like that
then on the ninth the Saturday at 12
p.m. we have my AMA session everybody is
welcome to join in on that get your
questions in early so I can hopefully
answer them at 3:00 p.m. we'll also have
the philosophy chat session for my
patreon supporters it's a perk that I
give them a sort of live interaction
with me video conferencing through our
video conferencing app
freeconferencecall.com then on the 11th
I'm driving down to Kenosha where
Carthage College has me coming in to
give a talk to their philosophy students
in the philosophy Club about how you can
actually live and make money outside of
the Academy doing philosophy so it's
kind of ironic that they brought me down
the the time that I'm actually teaching
a lot of classes within the Academy but
all of you know I've spent quite a bit
of time outside of the Academy building
a business and and doing things as well
the 14th which is a Thursday at 7 p.m. I
will be doing the next session of our
worlds of speculative fiction and this
time we're talking about GK Chesterton
and his novels of intrigue and rebellion
so of course we're doing the man who was
Thursday but we're also doing things
like the flying in and the ball and the
cross and a few other really cool novels
of his on the 22nd through the 24th I'm
gonna be quite busy here in town because
I'm gonna be attending a conference not
actually doing anything just attending
it
Richard Brandon is is coming in to give
the Aquinas lecture on the 24th and he
is having a conference that's been
organized here in his honor the two days
before that Robert brand I'm sorry so it
should be a really interesting
conference he is an analytic philosopher
who does analytic philosophy right and
thereby generally you know branches out
of analytic philosophy he does really
great history of philosophy and he's a
very important thinker so that'll be a
lot of fun on the 26th at 5:00 p.m. we
have our public half-hour Hegel Q&A and
discussion session again video
conferencing that's open to the general
public
anybody can can participate if they're
interested and then finally we end the
month
on the 28th the very last day of
February at 6 p.m. at the Shorewood
Public Library with the MKE stoic
fellowship meeting or still going
through Epictetus as discourses and we
will be discussing his chapter on
cynicism which is almost a treatise in
its own right what else
classes are ongoing I'm you know still
developing a lot of content and
assignments and things like that for
those classes eventually I'll roll some
of that into my teachable classes but
right now I'm so incredibly busy with
teaching every single morning is pretty
much occupied with
during the week I'm going to be doing
something new with a rexis D&O a TK as I
was mentioning so Rex is do you know n
TK is the blog that I first started
years and years ago when I was still a
full-time academic so I could write in a
more popular way and experiment with
shorter pieces that weren't intended to
become academic papers and over time I
did a lot of you know tinkering with it
the format you know published a lot of
other things use it for talking about
updates musings longer form articles but
I think nowadays you know my writing is
probably gonna be the longer form stuff
I'll do it in other places like medium
or partially examine life or you know
other other places stoicism today places
where I have invitations to write as
much as I want the conversation is
another one like that and I'm going to
reserve a rexis D&O at TK for writing
much shorter pieces that aren't trying
to resolve but rather just raise some
interesting philosophical issues and for
doing updates about the videos about the
podcasts about the events about you know
giveaways about other things that I've
got going on so I'm gonna actually try
something quite ambitious that is having
one entry every single day in or axis
dno at TK in the month of February and
then I'll reassess at the end we'll see
if that if it was a crazy idea if it was
too much work if it was something
possible if it paid off well in terms of
you know getting people interested in
the kind of work that I'm doing or
bringing together my different you know
viewer and supporter and subscriber
bases so that's one of the things I'm
going to be doing I also am going to be
working on some more popular pieces in
blogs and I've got some book projects
I'm still working on hopefully I'll be
able to carve out the time to do that
I'm actually putting together some
workshops as well video work I'm going
to be recording a lot of video and most
of it is for my classes I've got a
record video and augustine's on for each
so the will Anselm's on free choice
freedom of choice Lawrence Kohlberg I
need to get those knocked out right away
from my students who I meet with
actually tomorrow on his stuff immoral
development some stuff on a gar and
emotivism some stuff on Thomas Aquinas
some stuff on decart
and even some stuff on Iran for the
egoism discussion happening in about a
week in another one of my classes so
I've got a lot of core concepts stuff I
have to knock out and you'll see some of
that released this month and next month
in the month after that I also hope to
record a few personal videos about
things that I'm particularly interested
in and that people have been asking me
about I still have book review videos to
get to and I'm awfully behind and remiss
in those but I hope to get to some of
those this month
obviously I aim to shoot my full quota
of six half-hour Hagel videos this month
and I may shoot some Q&A videos of the
sort that I shot you know much earlier
on stoicism and if I have the time there
are some things I'm kind of riled up
about at the moment and I think I would
like to do some Sadler soapbox videos
but it's a matter of actually finding
the time so in addition to that I should
be able to start you know releasing some
new podcast material and say other
lectures depending on how much time I
get to actually edit the material and I
may be going on a few other podcasts and
radio shows this month as well but no
definite plans for that yet so that's
that's a lot going on in this short
month of February yeah quite a bit so I
hope that all of you have a great
February and if you're doing something
on Valentine's Day we're actually
pushing our Valentine's off in part
because I have to give a talk on
Valentine's Day
we're pushing it off to the weekend I
hope that you have a great time and
maybe I'll see some of you in these
online events or face-to-face
you